Trascrizione: Lucia Cadamuro
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quanto sono davvero liberi,
i nostri desideri?
Vorrei ragionare con voi su questo:
e per farlo, prendo in prestito
un ricordo lontanissimo
che credo che la maggior parte
di noi abbia in comune.
È un film che abbiamo visto
quando eravamo bambine e bambini:
"La storia infinita".
lLa trama ve la ricorderete:
Bastian è un ragazzino,
costretto a vivere una realtà
che gli dà grande sofferenza;
e per sfuggire a questa realtà
si rifugia nei libri,
cioè nel mondo dell'immaginazione
e della fantasia.
Un giorno, così facendo,
si imbatte in un libro molto speciale,
"La storia infinita", appunto,
che narra dell'avanzata del "Nulla",
una forza misteriosa e distruttrice
in grado di far scomparire
il vasto impero di Fantasia.
Bastian, leggendo,
segue per pagine e pagine
le avventure del giovane guerriero Atreju,
attraverso tutta una serie
di prove e pericoli,
per cercare di fermare questo nulla.
Ma non ci riesce:
niente e nessuno
sembra in grado di riuscirci.
Fino a quando Bastian
non si accorge di una cosa.
Si accorge che il vero protagonista
della storia che lui sta leggendo
è lui stesso,
è lui l'unico in grado
di poter salvare Fantasia,
lo sconfinato impero
dell'Infanta Imperatrice
che nel libro dal quale il film è tratto
viene anche chiamata
la "Sovrana dei desideri".
E non è finita qui!
Non solo quello che fa
Bastian nella realtà
è in grado di cambiare la trama
del libro che sta leggendo;
ma anche quella storia
è in grado di trasformare
la realtà in cui vive Bastian.
L'autore ci sta quindi dicendo
che il mondo dell'immaginazione
e quello della realtà sono connessi,
c'è un continuo sconfinamento
di uno nell'altro;
ne deriverebbe
che la nostra capacità
di nutrire uno dei due mondi
influenza l'altro.
La nostra capacità di immaginare
è in grado di influenzare
la nostra realtà;
e a sua volta,
quello che viviamo e vediamo
è in grado di influenzare
la nostra capacità di immaginare,
e così via.
Secondo l'autore, poi,
c'è un ingranaggio preciso
che mette in moto questo meccanismo:
lo scopriamo alla fine del film
quando Fantasia è ormai distrutta
e non rimane nulla
se non un piccolo granello di luce;
nella scena è tutto buio
e, immersi in quel buio, i due mondi -
quello dell'immaginazione
e quello della realtà -
finalmente si toccano.
"Perché è così buio?" domanda Bastian:
ed è l'Infanta Imperatrice,
la sovrana dei desideri,
a rispondergli:
"All'inizio è sempre buio".
Ma, aggiunge,
"Fantasia può ancora risorgere
dai tuoi sogni, dai tuoi desideri.
C'è qualcosa che tu desideri?",
Mi è sempre piaciuta
questa idea del desiderio
come antidoto al nulla,
alle forze negative, distruttrici,
che noi incontriamo
nel mondo che abitiamo,
e anche in quello che ci abita.
Questa suggestione, io,
me la sono portata dietro
per tutto questo tempo.
Ancora oggi, quando io sono
disorientata, svuotata, depressa,
quando è tutto buio insomma,
io riparto da quella domanda:
"C'è qualcosa che tu desideri?"
Il desiderio spinge in avanti la vita:
desiderare ci sembra la cosa
più naturale del mondo,
ci sembra un processo spontaneo,
libero, fisiologico
che non ha bisogno di nient'altro
al di fuori che di sé stesso.
Ma non è così,
perché gli esseri umani
non possono desiderare
quello che non riescono a immaginare;
e possono immaginare soltanto
quello che hanno visto, vissuto,
o di cui in qualche modo
hanno fatto esperienza:
per esempio, attraverso le storie.
La letteratura, il cinema,
il teatro, l'arte in generale
accendono la nostra immaginazione;
ed è come se ci mettessero
di fronte a un enorme specchio,
in cui noi possiamo vedere chi siamo,
e anche chi potremmo essere.
Questo specchio ci rivela a noi stessi:
e nel contempo ci aiuta
a comprendere gli altri,
a capire il mondo e la vita
e a immaginarla diversa
da come noi la conosciamo.
Fa tutto questo non soltanto passando
attraverso la nostra parte razionale,
ma soprattutto attraverso l'emozione,
che uno è dei canali più alti, e potenti,
di conoscenza e trasformazione.
Allora lasciate che io vi parli
del mio mondo, che è il teatro,
in cui questo momento di rivelazione
è particolarmente evidente,
perché lo spettacolo a teatro,
lo sapete, si fa nuovo ogni sera;
e attori e attrici,
e spettatori e spettatrici,
fanno lo spettacolo assieme,
affacciati su quello
che Louis Jouvet definiva
"un cratere che fiammeggia in silenzio",
intenti a fare qualche cosa
che non va soltanto in profondità
ma soprattutto in altezza,
proiettato cioè
nella verticale dell'infinito.
Se questo scambio funziona,
il vero spettacolo
non avverrà sul palcoscenico
ma nella mente di chi sta
guardando e osservando;
e continuerà anche molto dopo
la chiusura del sipario,
riverberando per molto tempo
nella memoria di chi vi ha assistito
durante questa esperienza.
Quello che vediamo è capace
di cambiarci e di rinnovarci,
e lo facciamo insieme,
come noi qui stasera,
contribuendo a definirci come gruppo
e a costituire quello che Jung chiamava
l'inconscio collettivo:
quello che vediamo ci ispira,
ci orienta, ci guida
ed è capace di generare desiderio,
capace a sua volta, come abbiamo visto,
di trasformare la realtà.
Tutto questo è potente:
e come ogni potere, si porta dietro
una grande responsabilità.
Sono un'attrice, e sono un attivista:
sono una delle 28 attrici
che ha fondato l'associazione Amleta,
nata nel 2020
con lo scopo di contrastare le disparità,
le discriminazioni di genere e la violenza
nel mondo dello spettacolo.
Per anni, noi attrici abbiamo contribuito
a creare quello specchio
di cui parlavamo prima:
per anni abbiamo interpretato storie,
recitato in spettacoli,
dato voce a centinaia
e centinaia di donne.
Siamo state serve,
regine bisbetiche e allegre comari;
siamo state Giulietta e Cassandra,
Nora e Medea,
la signorina Julie e Alcesti;
siamo state un'infinità di madri,
di mogli, di figlie, di sorelle.
Abbiamo cioè avuto l'onore,
ma anche la responsabilità,
di rappresentare
le donne sul palcoscenico.
È capitato, ad un certo punto,
che qualcuna di noi
vivesse un certo disagio,
un malessere al quale
non riusciva a dare un nome;
e di accorgersi di non essere
la sola a provarlo.
Allora abbiamo fatto una cosa:
ci siamo messe assieme,
e abbiamo deciso di cominciare
a osservare quello specchio
con cui noi, ogni sera,
nutriamo l'immaginario
di spettatrici e di spettatori.
Per prima cosa,
abbiamo sostituito le sensazioni
con i numeri, con le cifre,
con le percentuali,
cioè con dei dati precisi,
inconfutabili e incontrovertibili;
abbiamo cominciato a contare
le presenze femminili
sui palcoscenici più grandi
e importanti d'Italia.
Quelli dei teatri che prendono
maggiori finanziamenti,
che raccolgono più pubblico
e che hanno maggiore visibilità.
E ci siamo da subito accorte
di una cosa piuttosto curiosa:
che più i palcoscenici
diventano grandi e importanti,
più le donne su questi
palcoscenici diminuiscono,
fino ad arrivare a queste percentuali:
sui palcoscenici più grandi
e importanti d'Italia,
le attrici sono il 36 per cento -36!
Ma se le attrici sono il 36 per cento,
indicativamente i personaggi femminili
sono il 36 percento,
cioè le donne rappresentate
su quei palcoscenici
sono il 36 per cento.
Questi sono i numeri di una minoranza.
Ma noi donne non siamo una minoranza,
noi siamo la metà del mondo,
e questi numeri non ci rappresentano.
E non solo.
Le registe, su questi palcoscenici,
sono solo il 17 percento circa;
le drammaturghe, il 15 percento.
Questo significa che l'80, 85 percento
delle storie che passano
su questi palcoscenici
è fatta da un uomo.
Lo sappiamo: le donne per secoli
non hanno potuto studiare,
non hanno potuto scrivere,
in alcune epoche non hanno
neanche potuto recitare.
Questi numeri raccontano la nostra storia,
questi numeri raccontano
la nostra oppressione.
In platea, poi,
c'è una situazione ribaltata,
cioè la maggior parte del pubblico
è formato da donne.
Che quindi pagano dei biglietti,
pagano degli abbonamenti
per sentirsi raccontare
delle storie scritte da uomini.
Il punto di vista con cui
si osserva il mondo è uno solo,
la voce con cui lo si racconta è una sola,
e tutto questo non è privo di conseguenze.
Come ha osservato
Chimamanda Ngozi Adichie,
raccontare un unica storia è pericoloso
perché crea stereotipi:
gli stereotipi sono narrazioni
fallaci e incomplete
che ci allontanano dalla vera conoscenza:
e soprattutto possono
trasformarsi in gabbie.
In queste gambe noi attrici
veniamo messe molto presto,
impariamo molto presto, quindi,
quali sono gli stereotipi
che pesano sulle donne:
sono stereotipi sul nostro corpo,
sulla nostra età,
stereotipi sulle nostre capacità,
sulla nostra emotività,
stereotipi su quelli
che sono i nostri desideri.
Questi stereotipi hanno
un'idea di femminilità
che non ci appartiene, che non è reale:
e come disse Carla Lonzi,
l'immagine femminile con cui l'uomo
ha interpretato la donna
è stata una sua invenzione.
Se sei un'attrice,
per fare la protagonista
dovrei essere fatta in un certo modo.
Se hai una fisicità
che esce fuori dai canoni
lavorerai di meno, o ti faranno fare
sempre la stessa parte.
Dopo i 35-40 anni tenderai a scomparire,
oppure a finire
ai margini della narrazione
secondo uno schema
che si ripete da decenni
e che riguarda decisamente
molto meno gli uomini.
Quante volte abbiamo visto
il giovane principe Amleto
interpretato da attori
non più giovanissimi,
quante volte abbiamo visto
aitanti guerrieri
interpretati da attori
decisamente fuori forma?
Molto più raro vedere
una Desdemona, o una Giulietta,
interpretati da un'attrice
che non sia giovane e carina.
Dopo i 50 anni, sono pochissime
le protagoniste femminili,
mentre tantissimi sono i ruoli
di grandi e autorevoli vecchi.
Come nella vita, non si capisce
come mai gli uomini invecchiano
e diventano autorevoli,
e le donne invecchiano e scompaiono.
Sugli stereotipi riguardanti
le nostre capacità,
o meglio sarebbe dire incapacità,
che film, spettacoli,
persino cartoni animati
hanno contribuito a rafforzare,
noi potremmo stare qui per giorni:
le donne sono troppo emotive;
le donne sono dedite alla cura;
le donne non sono portate
per la matematica, per il comando;
le donne non sanno far ridere;
per le donne, la cosa più importante
rimane sempre l'amore,
l'uomo è il creatore,
e la donna è la sua musa;
e poi insomma, se noi non abbiamo avuto
grandi artiste, grandi scrittrici,
grandi poete, grandi pittrici,
ci sarà una ragione, no?
Certo che c'è una ragione,
ma non riguarda le capacità delle donne:
riguarda la dimensione politica e storica
che ha plasmato il mondo
è che è legata alla diversa distribuzione
del potere tra i generi:
le architetture patriarcali
si sono fondate
su oppressioni e condizionamenti
più o meno visibili,
e hanno disegnato il mondo
come noi lo conosciamo.
Le rappresentazioni, molto spesso,
hanno contribuito
a rafforzare quegli schemi,
invece di svelarne la mistificazione.
Ma se le donne, le ragazze, le bambine
non si vedono rappresentate,
o si vedono rappresentate
solo in funzione degli uomini,
se non vedono rappresentata
la loro complessità
ma si vedono appiattite
su ruoli e interpretazioni bidimensionali,
allora introietteranno l'idea
di non essere interessanti,
di non essere centrali
nella costruzione della trama del mondo,
o di esserlo solo a patto di avere
quelle caratteristiche
che il desiderio, e lo sguardo maschile,
proietta su di loro.
Quindi,
la rappresentazione non sta nutrendo
la loro capacità di immaginare;
e allora è proprio il meccanismo
del desiderio che si inceppa,
andando a compromettere
la loro capacità di generare realtà.
Voglio fare soltanto un esempio,
che riguarda uno stereotipo
piuttosto affermato
secondo la quale le donne
non sarebbero portate per la scienza.
Allora, nella scienza
come in molti altri campi
l'assenza di donne
ha delle ragioni storiche.
Le donne non hanno potuto studiare,
laurearsi, lavorare in quelle discipline.
E anche quando sono riuscite a farlo,
hanno visto le loro scoperte
prese e attribuite a degli uomini.
E guardate che questo fenomeno
è stato così diffuso
da meritarsi un nome
tutto suo: "effetto Giuditta":
quindi, le scienziate sono state
cancellate prima dalla realtà,
e poi dalle rappresentazioni
che di quella realtà sono state fatte.
Ecco, noi non abbiamo dati
che possano indicarci
quale impatto negativo
abbia avuto questa mancanza
nelle rappresentazioni sulla realtà;
però abbiamo dei dati che possono aiutarci
a fare dei ragionamenti.
Per esempio, nel 1993 la serie "X-Files"
fece impennare le iscrizioni di ragazze
a materie scientifiche;
e secondo una ricerca riportata
dal Geena Davis Institute,
il 63% delle donne
che lavora in materie STEM
ha affermato
che il personaggio di Dana Scully,
interpretato dall'attrice
Gillian Anderson,
è servita loro
da role model e ispirazione.
Questo viene chiamato "The Scully effect".
Così come il personaggio
della scienziata forense Catherine Willows
interpretato dall'attrice
Marg Helgenberger in "CSI",
ha contribuito a far aumentare
in maniera esponenziale
le iscrizioni di ragazze
in quella materia scientifica:
viene chiamato il "CSI Effect".
E a proposito di scienza,
la scoperta dei neuroni specchio,
e il loro ruolo nell'acquisizione
delle informazioni,
e i meccanismi neurali
che stanno alla base
dell'interpretazione, e dell'elaborazione,
di noi e di ciò che noi vediamo,
la riorganizzazione
dei comportamenti e delle proiezioni
secondo delle proprietà
predittive del cervello -
la scienza in pratica
ha confermato, piano piano,
il rapporto tra rappresentazione,
immaginazione, realtà e desiderio
che una trama di fantasia,
come quella de "La storia infinita",
aveva semplicemente ipotizzato.
E cioè:
se io vedo, posso immaginare;
se io immagino, posso desiderare;
se io desidero, ho il potere
di cambiare la mia realtà;
e se io cambio la mia realtà,
a poco a poco trasformo il mondo.
Vedere è potere.
Oggi noi abbiamo parlato di donne:
ma soltanto per svelare il meccanismo.
Ma intere categorie di persone,
ancora oggi in Italia,
sono completamente escluse
dalle nostre rappresentazioni:
dove sono le persone nere?
Le persone trans?
Le persone con disabilità?
Le persone appartenenti
a categorie marginalizzate?
Tutte quelle persone che fanno parte
della nostra vita, insomma:
dove sono?
Sul piano simbolico,
si gioca una partita molto importante:
non si tratta soltanto di intrattenimento.
Quindi, da questa sera: domandatevi
cosa vi stanno facendo vedere;
domandatevi soprattutto cosa e chi
non vi stanno facendo vedere;
pretendete altro; scegliete meglio;
desiderate meglio;
cambiate il mondo.
Grazie.